Genki man what's up now oh no nice  jacket  up this whole thing I've had it for ages  when Jen's favorites  oh you've still got the tag on it  there's my queen come here give me some  sugar how bout that that was a week's  worth  so thanks what exactly are you doing  here well I just happen to have a sixth  sense when it comes to what my woman  needs and I saw this and I thought I'd  just run it on over no Big D this is my  Filofax from 2003 anytime you see a red  heart in the calendar it means that we  begged oh my god red excuse me Jane  Conan Schultz office Oh  whoa jakey boy boys that I heard squeak  yeah you chairs the squeaker all right 9  out of 10 times it's because of the  hydraulics so let me take a look under  the hood come up we see just three back  out again Joe okay come here baby  all right it's okay I'm just giving a  minute